よろしくお願いします
アッ
サッドアカタニューチェサンディッチェドーチェヨナローハターヴァカーソーアンターソーセヴェーウッタマポーリソーアッサッドアカタニューチェサンディッチェドー
チェヨナローハターヴァカーソーアンターソーセヴェーウッタマポーリソー
えっと うん この偈は突然見るとびっくりするような言葉なんですね
でも誰もこれなすなすでは解説しませんだけど
アッサドーっていうのは信仰っていうのは全くない
信頼っていうのは全くないっていうことで
アカタニューっていうのは恩知らずっていう意味なんですね
サンディッチェドーっていうのはこの
このハイウェイロバというこの待ち構えていて
この行く行く人を捕まって殺して泥棒をやっている人々なんですね
そんなような人がハターヴァカーソーっていうのは
もう何の隙間もないんだと
で その人こそ最高な素晴らしい人であるとという風に訳しちゃうと
何だこれという風にわからなくなりますね
とんでもない隙間のない残酷な人こそが
うん まあ微妙に言葉の遊びもありますが
まあ一応アッサドーっていうのは信仰がないということなんです
えーと まああの小さなエピソードがありまして
それもまあ作ったエピソードのように感じますけど
あるお坊さんたちのグループがね
お釈迦様のに挨拶に行ったところでお釈迦様が
この人々はもう悟りに達せられるぐらい
まあ今能力あるんだとわかって
じゃあそれで助けてあげなくちゃとと思ったと
それでサーリプッタ尊者が側にいたんですから
サーリプッタ尊者にいきなりあなたはね
この力ありますね 仏教で言う悟るために必要な能力はね
5つの力って あれはサッダーサティサマーディパンニャーと言って
サッダー確信すること
サティっていうのは気づき
サマーディは禅定 それからヴィリヤ精進すること
それからパンニャー智慧ですね
その 5つを育てれば解脱に悟りに達しますよと
それでお釈迦様が質問するんですね
あなたは このこの 5力を完成すれば完全たる涅槃に入れるのだということは信じていますか？と
そしたら いえ 信じてませんと答えるので
それ信じてませんよと言ったら
ブッダの教えでしょうね
それであのお坊さんたちが
なんてことか ここまで智慧の第一
第一人者のサーリプッタ尊者がブッダの教えを信じてませんというんだからね
まだまだ疑いっているんでしょうかねとか
頭の中で色々妄想を始めたんですね
お釈迦様があんた方は何言うのかいと
自分で真理を知らない人が
人の話に鵜呑みに話を鵜呑みにしなくちゃいけないんだと
愚か者たちはね しかし
サーリプッタ尊者が自分でちゃんと修行してね
力を完成して悟りに達しているんだから
何も信じる必要はないんだよと
誰の話も 自分でわかってるんだと
だから自分が悟りに達しているんだから
あえてブッダの教えを信じていますという必要もないんだと
それはもう確認しているんだからね
そういうことで 真理というのは自分で確認するべきだという話だそうですね
それで話終わり じゃあ次に行きましょうか
はい  そのストーリーっていうのは
この信じます 信じますかという一言葉
仏典ではかなりからかってるんです
で だから日本でもね あなたは神を信じますか？とかね
よく聞こえますからね
スピーカーで アホじゃないかということですね
仏教の立場はね 誰も信じる必要はないんだよと
だから仏教の立場は バカが何でも信じる
智慧のある人は信じませんよと
だって自分で調べればいいでしょうに
だからこの信仰っていうのはとても危険なものなんです
信仰もほとんどマインドコントロールですから
だから証拠ないものを信じるしかないでしょうに
そういう時点でもう頭がいかれているんです
何か信じてしまえば しまえばね
何か証拠が必要なんです
たとえあのシステムが分からなくても
何か証拠が必要ですね
例えば誰かがね 自分のハンドパワーでもう病気を治せると言ったら
まぁ病人が並んでいて
あの人手を当てた途端治る
手を出すと治る 手を出すと治るならば
まぁ証拠はありますね
この人は病気でしたし
今もうハンドパワーでも治しているし
あれ何やとはまだわからない
わからないんだけど やっぱり治ることはありますよと
いう程度ぐらいでも いわゆるこのからくりというか
この この理由がわからなくても
証拠がないと微かにでも信じることはできないんですね
だから仏教は信仰にはものすごい大反対というということだけ覚えておいてください
信じるということは やっぱりもう人間としてはもう本当に情けないことで
自分が自分の成長にもうすぐもう鍵をかけたことになるんですね
もう足にもうかなり重りをつけたことになります
もう進めなくなります
それから完全にマインドコントロールだけですね
で 信じたものをそちらから言われるまま
そのままそのまま信仰するしかないんですね
で この神の言葉とかね
例えば聖書は神の言葉だと
その人々本気で思っているんですね
しかし 調べてみれば もうギリシアで書いた本なんですね
いろんな人 あちこちで本はもう100 200
ぐらいあって その中である人が
エジプトのびしょっが好き勝手に 26冊をまとめちゃったんですね
それだけで その中でも古いという本というのは
ポールという人が書いたもので
あの人はイエス見たこともないし
で しかし全部神の言葉であると
だから矛盾いっぱいあるんですけど
それは神様が言ったんだからしょうがないだろうということで
人間の常識は使わないんですね
で 一番怖いのはね コーランなんかはね
あれっていうのは聖書ほどもう読みにくいんですね
もうものすごいおかしいんで
内容が 支離滅裂で ただ
二 三行読む毎に我こそ絶対的神で
我以外はもう誰も認めてはあかんぞという脅しばっかり
繰り返し繰り返しで それからもう神の名前
いろんな名前入れたりして
もう２００ ３０0ぐらいありますね
それは綺麗な声で歌うんですね
それですごい感動的に
なんで綺麗でしょうかとかね
だから発音を綺麗に歌えるように言葉を並べているみたいですが
内容はないんですね だからそれはわかりませんよとか偉そうなことを言ったりして
好き勝手な解釈したりして
人殺しに使ってるんですね
で イスラムの意味は平和の意味やと言ったら
その通りやと我々は認めなくちゃいけないんです
しかし コーランの中では平和の言葉というのは一つもないんです
何もない で 本気で言ってる
本当にイスラムというのは平和が出たとか
調べたらまた意味違うかもしれない
私はアラビア語知りませんからね
人の言う話に乗るしかないんです
そういうふうに信仰っていうことになってくると
それからマインドコントロールで終わってしまいますね
自分で判断してはいけないってことになりますね
だから それこそ人間にとってはとんでもない不幸なことなんです
人間っていうのは疑うことによって成長したんです
神だけを信仰していたならば
いまだに我々はもうもう原始人で
狩人と狩りと戦争ばっかりやって生活しているはずなんです
地球が平らだとかね そう思ったりして
しかし 人間がやっぱりあっちこっちがそれはどうかなとかね
疑う人が出てきて その人が物事を物事を調べるようになったりして
特にギリシャやらそういうところでね
哲学者たちの影響も 神を信じない人々もいましたからね
そういう人々の影響も派手にあって
論理 論述 論することやらね
そういうことでもやっともう幸福な世界がというかね
より発展した世界が現れてきたんですね
だから現実を見た方がいいんです
これはどうだいと もうちょっと怪しいとかね
そういうふうに調べると何か分かってくるんですね
そういうわけで 我々にはもう様々な発展があったんですね
豊作は神が与えてくれるものだと思っちゃうと
農業は開発しないでしょうに
でも人間がもう神がやってくれるまで待っていないで
自分たちであらゆる研究して
調べて調べて どうすれば豊作になるのかと
あれは調べて学ぶんです
田んぼに水を入れるべき時と
水をもう外すべき時とかね
それは今ちゃんと知ってるんですね
今日は水入れてやるぞとかね
それで日 サンシュ日経た
じゃあ全部水をまたもう返しちゃうとかね
肥料を入れる日があったりしてね
それはちゃんとあって
もう稲刈り ちゃんと計算して稲刈りをするし
で それって一つも神が教えてくれなかったんです
日本でもね 田んぼやってる方々はちゃんと湿度まで調べるんですね
空気の湿度まで調べて
この程度なら大丈夫だと
天気予報も聞いて 今日は稲刈りじゃあやっぱり今日はダメ
明日にしなくちゃいけないとかね
だからそれを一つも神様が教えてくれたもの
何もないんです だから聖書から見ればね
神様がね アダムがね 葉っぱ 1枚で体を隠したことにも腹が立ちましたからね
だからそういうのは人間があまりもうね
頭の理性のひとかけらもある 2 たす 2 は 4 だとぐらい程度でも分かっている人ならね
思うことではありませんだけど
だからこの現実的に見ると
やっぱり信仰っていうのはもうとんでもない邪魔なんです
人類にとっては ひどい目に遭うんですね
で なのにやっぱりもう信仰ばっかり謳っていて
謳っていて 日本の信仰宗教にしたってもね
全く単純に信仰でしょう
信仰ばっかり仰ぐんですね
で その時点で本当に人々には迷惑で
束縛されちゃって 自由がなくなって
言われるようになってしまって
愛する人間になってしまうんですね
それって人間としては情けないんでしょうね
だから 自分で調べる自由
自分で物事を発見する自由っていうのは
人間にはどうしても欠かせないものなんです
そういうことで 仏教はだいたいではなくて
もう断言的に まあ信仰には反対です
だからこのお釈迦様は一般的にあんまり私みたいなガチャガチャガチャガチャお釈迦様は理屈言いません
まあ一言葉でからかうだけで終わっちゃいます
まあ信仰するのはバカだと
自分で知らないんだから信仰するんだと
自分で調べたら信仰する必要ないんだと
例えば地球が丸いんだとあなたは信じますか？と聞いたら
それはもう無意味な質問なんですね
信じる必要ないんです
なぜかというと 地球は丸いということはもう証拠済みなんですね
微塵の間違いはありません
科学者は計算すると計算ちょっと間違ったとか
それはあり得ない だって
言ってみれば丸いんだからね
ですから それはもう信仰の対象ではないんです
しかし 最初にただ計算だけで地球が丸いと言ったんだから
計算もうに足すにいくつかわからなかった人々は
その人はもう殺してしまったんですね
神を侮辱したんだと だからその当時で知識人が計算して
やっぱりと推測 丸いと
計算的にはもう証拠は出ますということで
しかし現代になってくると
まぁそんなとは もう外を見てみればわかるということでね
で見えちゃいますからね
もうもう断言的にもう丸くなってますから
もう信じる必要はないんですね
だから仏教の場合はそのつのステップは必ずあるんです
で 例えば あの あらゆる証拠を調べて調べて
地球が丸いとまず決めてあったでしょうに
それで世紀になってからみんな宇宙船やらあれやこれやと作ったりして
それで宇宙に行ってみて
で 思い存分地球の写真やらビデオやら撮ったりして
あるいは二 三ヶ月間も宇宙に止まっていて
遠くから地球を見てね
言うと もう計算見れなくなっちゃうんですね
昔はね まぁ海でね 遠くから船を見ていると
先にあの 何でしたっけ
マスト見えるでしょうと
どんどんどんどんどんどん船が見えてくるんだよと
近寄ってくると それがこうやって丸いんだから
こちらにいると船のマストのとんがっているものね
で それしか見えませんと
しかし こうやって上がってくると
全部見えるんだよという
そうすると推測でしょ
しかし あ やっぱり地球は丸いとそれで決めておくんです
それが第一ステップ それからもう今宇宙に行って
そこで何ヶ月間も住んでみて
それ以上言うことはないでしょうに
で 仏教の場合もいろいろ
調べてね 仏陀の教えはやっぱりその通りだと納得いく
それにも信仰という でも何か数学的に答え出しただけで
それから修行して自分で経験する
それは宇宙のいっぱいステップなんですね
そうすると真理に対してはもうもう話にならない
もう事実であることには
ということで それは仏教の立場なんですね
そこを渡る何の関係ないんですね
信じますというと それでもう調べることはいらなくなりますね
そういうことで 僕はこのアッサドーっていうのは
まあ人の話を信じて納得いくんじゃないんだと
この信じるというこの弱みを全くもうなくなっている
だから修行して悟りに達した人がもう全て真理知ってるんだから
何か信仰するの？これからとかね
もう消えてるんですね
で 私たちも私たちなりにいろんなことを調べますけど
調べられないものっていうのはあまりにもありますね
その場合はマスコミの報道を信仰する羽目になっちゃうんですね
政府の発表を信仰する羽目になっちゃうんです
政府の発表っていうのは
大体年 年経ってくると
もうあれは嘘でしたということはね
堂々と嘘を発表してね
いろいろやったりしたりして
で しかし政府はこんなことはありません
こんなことはありませんから
あれやこれや言ったっても
我々にはその資料にはアクセスできません
禁止 立ち入りも禁止 これに年
年経って その連中も死んでしまってからはい
開放しますよ 情報は それでいろいろ研究者たちがね
当時どうこんなことを言って日本人は黙っていましたとか
あれこれ今更言ったっても
もうどうしようもないんですね
同時に現代はもう騙されていて
それであと年ぐらい経ったら
やっぱり我々のひ孫たちがね
あの連中はまんまと騙されたんだよと言われるでしょうね
我々としては 戦争中と戦後の時期は日本人は騙されていたと今更言ったっても
我々も同じことでね はい
それで言いたかったのはこういうこと
私たちは騙されては欲しくないし
自分たちで調べたいんだけど
そんなに今のことは調べられないんですね
何でもかんでも そうなってくると
医者が言うことも信じるし
マスコミで報道することも信じてしまいますね
ということは 私たちにとっては未だにこのこの弱みがあるんですね
信じる弱み があるんです
それ消えたらもう悟りに達しているんです
で まあ世間の現象はね
知ったとしても知らなくてもね
そんなに役に立ちません
なぜかというと 毎日変わりますからね
今 世の中でね 本当のこと
本当のことということもね
週間ね また変わってしまいます
1週間前まではね 日本と中国は結構仲がいいと
中国人もバンバン日本にもう
もう何て言いますか もうしがみついて旅行するんだと
あれやこれやとか言って威張ってたんですけど
今ちょっと関係がね おかしくなって
だからこれ 1日で変わるもんですね
世の中のことは だから
そういうことを知り尽くすということは
もうありえないし どうでもいいんです
世間のことはその都度その都度
もう理性でもって対応すればいいんです
しかし 知るべきことっていうのは
生きるとは何やっていうことなんですね
そこは仏教で修行することで知り尽くすことはできます
それっきり 誰にもその人を騙すことはできませんし
何かあなた信じますか？というと
全然何も信じるものはなくなっているんです
信じる必要はないんですね
そういうことで お釈迦様がそこを仏教に
ブッダの教えにわざとその態度を入れてるんですね
鵜呑みにしてはいけません
例えば八正道っていうのは
誰が見たっても立派な教えでしょうに
仏教はすごい反対している
嫌がっている人にしたっても
これはおかしいとは言えないでしょうね
ブッダが正しい言葉を語ると言っている
あれっておかしいんだと
人間というのは正しくはない言葉を語るべきではないかとは言えないでしょう
しっかりとした正しい生き方で生計を立てなさいと
八正道 正見はありますね
あれっておかしいと 言えますかね
不正的に生きるべきではないかと
あらゆる詐欺で詐欺行為で
あらゆることで人を騙してお金を巻き上げて生活することの方が正しいでしょうにとは言えないでしょうに
やっていても だから八正道が間違っていると他宗教の方々にも言えないし
仏教にはものすごい断固反対という人にも言えないはずなんです
だからとお釈迦様は注意するんです
仏教徒に 鵜呑みにするなよと
だから仏教のこの信じないというレベルというのはかなりレベル高いんです
常識的にはこれは事実でしょうに
常識的に見れば それでもダメだよと
人類の常識 みんなの人類の常識から見ても
四聖諦八正道というのはそのままなんです
変わらないんです いまだに誰にも間違っているというふうにね
一言葉も言えなかったんだから
まだに だから仏教は事実だ
私は信じますとはダメです
だから まあある程度で
あの船のマストを見て
ああ 地球が丸いと思うような感じで
まあある程度でブッダがしっかりしたことを教えられているんだとは納得する
それで完成しませんね
それから自分で実験してみる
実験して 自分で発見してみる
それが まああのロケットに乗って宇宙に行ったような感じで
外から見てみる というと
もう丸いと見えるような感じで
ブッダに説かれた教えがそのまま事実であると自分でわかるんですね
ということは 信仰はもうひとかけらもなく
もう壊しているんです
だから 正しく見えるものも
それなりに証拠を揃っているものも
やっぱり証拠はありますよぐらいで
確実に事実ということはもうちょっと弱いんです
この裁判かける場合はね
やっぱり証拠を揃って出すでしょうに
だから明確に有罪ということというのは
どうもすごく決めにくいんですね
証拠が揃っていても どこかでちょっと微妙に曖昧さががある
です いわゆるブッダの教えを学んでみると
反論はできないし 学んでみたらそのまま
ああ なるほど これは事実というふうに
我々は納得いくんだけで納得いくんだけど
それでもって断言的に
これこそ正しい 他はみんなダメよ
嘘だって それは言うんじゃないんです
まだまだ我々は推測でいくらか納得しているだけで
実験して自分で試してないんです
それで修行をすると この信仰の弱みが心から消えてしまいます
だからアッサドーと言うんです
だから信仰は一欠けらもないではなくて
信仰でもう結実に達する弱みがもうなくなって乗り越えているんです
信仰するようなもう情けないだらしない人間ではありません
もう成長しているんです
アカタンニューというのは
そのまま辞書を引いてみれば
もう御白洲なんです これはどう解説すればよろしいんですかね
アカタンというのは このこれはアカタンニューというよりもアカタンという言葉なんです
意味がちょっと違います
それはちょっと言葉遊びで
わざとお釈迦様が使っている単語なんです
アカタンというのは涅槃という意味なんですね
カタというのは何か作られたという
カタというのは作られたもの
出来上がったもの 出来上がったものというのはすべて壊れます
因縁によって出来上がるんです
何でもかんでも だから物事はずっと変わって変わって
絶えず変わっていくんです
何一つも一定しないんです
我々の心も体も世界も宇宙も
何でもかんでも頭で考える概念もね
知識も何一つも止まらないんです
変化して変化して変化して
壊れて壊れて壊れていくんです
なぜならば全て作られたものなんです
作られたものに また別にパーリ語ではサンカーラというんですね
あの漢字でね 行という漢字ですけどね
見えるもの 聞こえるもの
何でもかんでもサンカーラですね
作られたもの 作られたというのは誰かが作るという意味ではなくて
だからそう誤解するんだから出来上がるもの
いろんな因縁でいろんなものはもう出来上がっちゃいます
子供は誰かが成長させてるわけじゃなくて成長するんです
ある子供が言ったすごい面白い言葉があるんです
あの 私は育ててもらうんじゃないんだと
育ちますと で 全くね 親には手がかからない
随分すくすく育つ子なんですけど
全部自分一人でしっかりとやってるんです
兄はもう全くももう何も面倒くさい迷惑というということはまるっきりない
0 早く寝なさいとか起きなさいとかいう必要もまるなし
勉強しなさい 宿題しなさいと言わん
全部やる 自分で それで
もうこの子には手は全然かかってかからないなと喜んだところで
私は育ててもらうんじゃなくて育ちますというんです
だからすごい賢い言葉なんですよ
子供なりに言うような
そういうわけで 育て 育ててあげるということはあり得ません
できません 育ちます 育つ
育ちますということも変わりませんでしょうに
一定しないという意味でしょうに
そういうことで この作られたものという日本語訳すると
なんか誰が作ったんでしょうか？とすごいアホな質問が頭に浮かんじゃうんですね
ではなくて 全て生命全体
宇宙全体 全て変化して変化して変化して変化してま
いくものなんです そういうものにはサンカーラというし
形っていうのはそういうこと
形 作られたもの 出来上がったもの
アカタっていうのはその反対ですね
それは乗り越えた境地
ということは涅槃なんです
アカタニョーっていうのは
それはもう自分で知っている
涅槃っていうのは体験するしかもう頭で理解はできません
頭っていうのは作られたものだからね
頭にはほんのわずかな情報しか処理できません
頭は目に見えるもの 耳で聞こえるものを
そのデータをね 合成して合成して合成して現象作って
この現象を知ったことにするんです
だから本物は知らないんですね
頭では 目を開けて何か見ていると
この本当に目に入る情報は我々は認識しないんです
その代わりに情報をまとめて合成して
他の概念も合わせて新しい概念を作ったり
新しい現象を作ったりするんです
だから脳が勝手なんですね
だからみんなに目があるんだけど
我々には色見えるというのはそれぞれ人によって違うんですね
みんな同じ音を聞いても
それぞれ頭の中で起こる認識はその人によって違います
だから この聞いたり見たりする世界っていうのは全く信頼できない世界になってます
私は私が作った幻覚の中に閉じ込めていて
他の人はその人が作る幻覚の中に閉じ込められているんですね
それって脳の働きですね
そういうことだから 涅槃は
じゃあ頭で理解しますと
よく理解できませんだから説明してくれと私に頼んでも
それはもう認識の管轄外なんですね
五感から情報を得て理解する認識の管轄外なんです
それだったら自分で経験するしかないんです
経験した人が説明すればいいでしょうに
だけど 言葉がないんです
で それが悟りに達した人
解脱に達した人にアカタニョーと言うんです
まあサンディッチェで次の単語に行きます
はい サンディっていうのは道路のジャンクションですね
交差するところ はい 道路で考えれば
高速道路で考えてもいろいろジャンクションがありますね
東名ば左と甲府は右やとかね
こちらに乗っちゃえばね
ここら辺に上っていると
左にどこかで曲がっちゃえば
そのままそのまま東名高速に入ったり
右に曲がったら別のところに行ったりとか
そういう風にいろいろジャンクションがあるんですね
ということは まあ大阪からも東京につなげてますね
高速道路は で 北の方からもちゃんとつなげています
仙台からでもどこからでも
やっぱり高速道路でつなげてます
どこにつなげていますかね
ジャンクションでつなげています
あのジャンクションなかったらどうしようもない
たまにジャンクションないところもありまして
そこで高速道路から降りて普通の国道で行って
また別な高速道路に乗るというところもありますけど
これジャンクション作っちゃえばもう大丈夫ですね
サンディっていうのはそういう働き
ある地方と別な地方をつなげておくんです
はい そのサンディを壊す
壊すんです で こちらの地方から人がずっと道路で歩いてくると
そちらから右に曲がって別な方向に行かなくちゃいけないけど
そこにジャンクションがないんですね
ないならばもう行けなくなっちゃいますね
仏教では じゃあこのサンディって何ですかね
人間というのは一つの生まれが終わった瞬間で
次の生まれに行くんです
ちゃんとジャンクションができているんです
人間界から地獄にも落ちられるし
畜生にも行けるし 餓鬼道にも落ちられるし
天界にも行けるんです
もし交通料金払えるならば
梵天界にも行けるし 他はまあそれほど難しくないんです
天界から地獄までは 無料かして
まあ無料でもないんですけど
梵天に行きたければ やっぱり瞑想してサマーディを作らなくちゃいけないんです
このサマーディの力でそのジャンクションは通過できます
他はまあ善と悪行為によってまあ簡単に通過できます
というわけで この 倫理のことなんですね
私たちは死ぬ瞬間で やっぱりたくさんいろんな行為をしてね
善も悪もいっぱいやってるんだから
行為をしないでいることは不可能です
だからどんな人の心も業がいっぱい溜まってます
毎日溜まるんです 毎分業が溜まるんです
何を？私は何もやってないんだよと言ったっても
生きること自体何かやってることなんです
行為なんです 何もやらないで生きるっていうことってありえないんです
だから私は何もやってないっていうことは
何もやらないという行為しているんです
ただじっと待っているという行為しているんです
それによって善悪が生まれるんです
何もやらなくたって 頭でいろんなこと考えているんだからね
であまりにも怠けちゃって
もう寝ぼけちゃっていると
それは考えてないでしょうね
あれも行為なんです 寝ぼけて居眠りしながらいたんだと
考えることもあまりしなかったと言ったっても
それも悪行為なんです
だって無知を育ててるんだからね
その時間で 太刀落としながら稲むらしながらじーっといるんですね
何も考えも本も読まない
その場合は無知が結構もうバンバン溜まっていくんです
悪行為なんです あるいは考えているんだと
それも考える内容によって悪行為になったり善行為になったりするが
善行為になることというのはまず考えないんですね
かっこ悪いんだから 慈しみのことって誰も考えないでしょ
何食いますか？とかね
何をして遊ぶのかとか
そればっかり考えてるでしょうね
どうすれば人を助かるのかとかね
世界って随分無常で変わるもんだなとかね
自分を死ななくちゃあかんなとかね
そういうことを考えないでしょ
かっこ悪くてね どうすれば長生きできるのかい？とかね
みんな死んじゃっても
自分だけどうやってしないのでいられるかとかね
そういうことを考えてるんだから
一人で考えてる場合はもうまず悪行為なんです
稀なケースで まあ良いことも考えますけど
すぐ嫌になっちゃうんですね
そういうわけで 生きるということは行為をすることなんです
行為には結果があるんです
だから結構エネルギーは溜まってるんです
そこで死んでももうジャンクションができてます
で すぐどこかで生まれてしまうんですね
このジャンクションというのはちょっとわかりにくいんですね
これは死にたくはないという気持ちなんです
死にたくはないっていうのは
ポジティブ的に言えば生き続けたいってことなんです
ネガティブで言えば死にたくはない
それは別な用語で 仏教用語で言えば渇愛なんです
これがジャンクションです
渇愛というちゃんとトールゲートができてあって ETC
みたい まあ通ればいいんで
もうちゃんともうその分の料金は取られてるんです
だから全部使ってるんじゃないんです
皆様は 高速道路でね 今銀行落としでしょ
トールゲート通っただけで銀行の口座全部残高取ったってありえないでしょうね
その料金分だけしか取りませんよ
また教えてもくれるしね
料金は 四百五十円ですとかね
あのなんか機械入れてありますからね
今どんな車にも 口座にはいくら残高あってもあれしか取りません
それで私 私たちは業がいくらあっても
畜生に落ちる場合はその料金分だけ取れるんです
餓鬼道に落ちる場合は
その料金分だけ取れるんです
ここまだ溜まってます
まだ活動やりますから
もうジャンクションはどこにでも行けます
というわけで 生命っていうのは
誰も信じていようがなかろうが関係なく輪廻転生するんです
だから人が輪廻転生したいかないかって知る方法っていうのは簡単です
死にたくないでしょ？生き続けたいでしょ
では自殺する人はそれだったら解脱ですね
だって生きたくはないんだからね
そんな話になると そういう反論が成り立ちますね
生きていきたい 死にたくないと思っている人はみんな輪廻転生するんだぞと言ったら
俺は生きていけるものだ
私はもうとにかく自殺したいやという人は解脱するのかいと
で 逆です あれがあまりにも希望が高すぎちゃって
生きることに 自分の妄想と現実の隔たりがありすぎちゃって腹が立って死ぬだけ
だから普通生きている人よりも生存欲はものすごい強烈なんです
自殺する人は欲があんまりにもありすぎちゃって
それは怒りに変わっただけ
あの 溜まり過ぎは危ないんですよ
いろいろあのね 水をダム作って溜ま溜めてもらうでしょ
それで電気も作ったりしてかなり助かりますね
しかし 突然ダムにいっぱい水が溜まっちゃうと
ダムが崩壊しちゃって大変な損害を与えるんです
そんな感じで この生存欲
生きていきたいという欲があまりにも現実離れまでになってくると
まあ自殺するんですね
だからその人々も当然転生はします
で 存在欲を足らない 足さない限りはね
輪廻転生はします だから私たちの心にはジャンクションというのはよくできています
それで通過するために必要な業もあまりにも溜まってるんです
いつでも溜まるんです
1分ごとに大量に溜まるんだから
減るということはないんです
それだったらもうどうなるんですかね
料金上でも 例えば 100円しか取れないと思ったところで
自分にはもう 1兆円もあるんだと
それで 100円入っただからといって
あの金には痛くも痒くもないでしょう
だから輪廻転生する場合も
我々が使う業っていうのは
1兆円から 100円程度でもなくてもっと巨大なんです
溜まってる業は それを知らないほどたくさんあります
どこに生まれ変わるためには
ほんのわずかな業で十分です
こんなわずかな業で 人間界に生まれるのは難しいだけで
数少ないんですからね
アリ塚見てもどれぐらいいるんですかね
生命は すごいたくさんいるでしょ
だから世の中 我々 我々知ってる生命の中でも
昆虫やらアリとか虫とか見てみると
数は数はものすごいでしょうね
いくらでも生まれますよ
しかし その他の生命と人間の数は比較にならないほど人間の数が少ないんですね
だからこのバイリスがね
業があってもあまりにも高いんだから
人間界には入りすごい入りづらいんです
他ところどこでも簡単に行きます
だから地獄にはとても簡単に落ちやすいし
餓鬼道にも落ちやすいし
畜生に落ちやすいし 天界にも行きやすいんです
そちらは人口管理はありません
どこでも 人間の世界だけ
やっぱり人口管理が起きてるんです
まあそれ以外はどこでも行けますよ
で 私たちには生きていきたいというね
死にたくないという気持ちが当然あるし
ということで 死んだ瞬間であのジャンクションができてますからね
すぐ繋げているんです
ですから 困ったり考えたり
どこに生まれようかなとかね
そういうことって全く要らないんです
瞬時にもう変わって終わってるんです
なんかここら辺ちょっと散歩をすると
ここら辺渋谷区ですけど
けどちょこちょこ散歩して回るみたいな
新宿区なんですね ほんの五分歩いただけですよ
新宿区 こちら辺に行けばね
ここら辺ちょこちょこっと歩いてみたら
世田谷区 何の事もない
別にこれから新宿区から新しい別な区に別な役所を受けて管理する世田谷区に入りますよとか
はい 世田谷区へどうぞとかね
何もないんです もうジャンクションってできてます
同じ道路ですから たまに大きい道路だったらちょこっと看板がある場合もあるし
ない場合もあるし で 甲州街道で向こうからね
八王子の方からね もう八王子も東京だからね
もっと遠くからね 来ていると
もう東京都に入るでしょうに
これぐらいの看板があるだけです
東京都見えないしね 何の事なく道路を繋げているんですね
そういうような感じで死んだらもう生まれるんです
このサンディを壊すんです
解脱っていうのは お釈迦様ね
だからお釈迦様はすごいヒューマーだから
ユーモアだから こういう単語を使っても
本当はサンディチェードっていうのは
あの あの あの古いあのアメリカの映画あるでしょ
あの あの何映画というんですか
このあのカウボーイ映画みたいなね
アメリカのアクション映画ありますね
この前の手待ち構えて電車強盗するとかね
もうそういう そんな感じで待ち構えていて
もうみんな殺して 全部財産強盗して逃げているという泥棒のことなんです
チェードっていうのは
英語で言うハイウェイロバ
ハイウェイにこう ハイウェイっていうのは高速道路っていう
じゃなくて あの遠いところに行く道路っていう意味なんですね
すごいなんかすごい遠いところに浮かび出来てるって
だからそこで村から町から町へとかね
国から国へつなげるところはどうしても道路だけあって
周りはもう巨大な森とかね
山とかね あって しかし
国から国へ行く人々はもうたくさん車を並ぶ
馬車 馬とか馬車とかいろいろ並べて品物を入れて
まあ行くと どこかで森の中へ
どこにみんな隠れていて
みんな捕まって殺して戦災産取るという恐ろしい泥棒なんですね
サンディッチエドっていうのは
なのにお釈迦様はもっと同じ単語を別な意味で使っている
サンディッっていうのは
街と街をつなげるところ
それで仏教から見れば
一つの生まれから別のあまりに転換するところ
それは壊してくださいと
壊した人は死んでから行くところはなくなっちゃうんですね
それで解脱に達するということになるんです
うーん 次の単語は何でしたっけ
アワカーソっていうのはもう隙間っていうことで
あの まあチャンスっていう
チャンスっていう言葉で理解することもできますね
チャンスは全部壊してるんですね
っていう意味で どんなチャンスかというと
どんな隙間かというと
もう無料の業を持ってるんです
誰でも 修行する人もみんな
あえて我々はよく言う徳の高い人とか言うんだけど
あれあんまり意味のある単語じゃないんです
徳であろうか 悪業であろうか
高い低いと言えるものじゃないんです
誰でも無料に持ってるんです
ここで使用する業の差が見てそう言うんですね
本当はもうあなたは徳が高いとかね
私は徳の低い人間やとかね
言っても あれは事実ではありません
みんな同じ大量に業持ってます
こう言えば 私の今の生命を
今の命を司ってる業の方が力が弱いんだと
今のログインしている業の力が弱いんだと
しかし 大量の業はほとんどみんな同じ量を持ってます
それで この大量の業に
あの 転生させるという能力が入っているんです
あの業には二つの能力があるんです
転生する 維持管理する
維持管理にはそんなにまあ難しくないんです
業 業にはちょっとすごいパワー必要ですね
あの転生させるために
どんな行為にもその二つの力が当然ついてるんです
転生させる能力と維持管理する能力
だから我々人間に生まれたんですね
それで過去の何かの業が転生させる力を
その権を使っちゃったんです
それから残っているのは維持管理
同じ業が死ぬまで維持管理するんです
ここで人間界で生まれた業がありまして
生まれた瞬間で誕生させる業の機能は終わり
生まれ 生まれ 産ませ 産ませたんだから
誕生させたんだから それから生まれ
お腹に お腹に産まれることです
お産することじゃないんです
仏教では お腹にもう誕生しちゃったんですね
それからその子はどうしましょうか
心配だわとか思って 思う必要はないんです
それからあの業が全部管理するんです
それはろくな業ではない場合は
もう何て言いますか あの
アトピーになったり もう食べ物はよく消化できなかったりとかね
いろいろありますけど
それぞれの方の維持管理の力の差なんですね
病弱になったり 健康になったりとかね
オリンピックに出るぐらいのいい体格で生まれたりとかね
まあいろいろ そこで大量の業があって
無量の業には生まれるというね
誕生させる能力がある場合はかなりやばいんです
悪行為をして地獄に落ちるとしますね
だから悪行為が一個の悪行為がこの生まれ誕生させるパワーを使って地獄に落としちゃうんですね
それからあの業が維持管理するんです
長い間地獄の中で だから維持管理って言葉かっこいいんだけど
地獄の人はね ずっと苦しまなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それがそちらの維持管理なんです
それって面白いんですよ
人間で生まれたら いじめられたり
苦しめられたり 手足が潰れたりすると死んじゃいますね
我々は美味しいご飯を食べたり
体をいろいろ面倒見てあげたりすると生き続けられます
それは人間界の業なんですね
楽しく生活すると結構生き続けられます
環境のいいところに住んだりして
きれいな水を飲んだり
美味しいご飯を食べたり
適当に運動したりとかね
人々と仲良くしたりすると
結構もう明るく生きられます
その業がそう管理してくれるんです
で それは人間界のことで
じゃあ地獄の人は？これ悪行為だから逆なんですね
逆になっていかに苦しみのかと
だから苦しめば苦しむほど地獄で生き続けられます
それ悪行為の維持管理なんです
で 我々は人間界というのは大体長官的だから
微妙にこの型隠れてるんですね
何か DNA みたいな感じで
この自分をいじめることで刺激感じる人々いるでしょ
そうでないと退屈ですね
いろんな方法で自分をいじめるんですね
自傷というんですか 自分自分で自分に怪我させたり
あるいはあえて行って喧嘩したり
ああいうことは極限的になってくると地獄なんですね
人間にはそこを例えばもうプロレスラーになって
もうくったくった体いじめて怪我して
あれもう最高に気分がいいんだとか
ハイになってるんだと言っても
もう死にますよ ちょっとしたちょっと超えたところで自傷したっても
ちょっと間違ったら死にますからね
まああれでちょこっと地獄の働きのは
ひとかけら隠れているんですね
地獄に落ちたらそれが表に出てきてとことん苦しくなるんですね
そうなってくると いくらでも地獄で長生きすることはできます
苦しめば苦しむほど餓鬼道も同じ
餓鬼道っていうのはもう派手に幻覚で悩む次元なんですね
恐ろしい幻覚ばっかしででは悩んでいる
だからいくらでもそういうのは現れてくる
だから業を管理するっていうことが
もう言葉通りにすごいかっこいいというわけでもないんです
人間 天界 梵天というところでは
幸せにしてあげることで管理する
人間以下は不幸にすることで管理になるんです
そこでこの無量な業が
これパーリ語では種というんですね
種持ってるんですね 種という結構いい単語です
卵見ても ひよこになるこのことっていうのはほんの小さいんです
でっかいあるでしょう
黄色いところと白いところ
あれは栄養分なんです
だからビージャという言葉
ビージャですね パーリ語では卵も種も同じ単語なんです
ビージャというんです
だから小麦見ても 米というか何でしたっけ
もみ 皮があって芽が出るところ
ほんの小さいんです しかし
もみが結構大きいでしょう
あれ大きいところは栄養分なんです
だからもみの芽が出てくると
栄養分がどんどん消えちゃって
消えてるとでっかい稲になってるんです
だから業にはビージャという言葉を使うんです
カンマビージャ 卵で考えれば卵もビージャという言葉を使うしね
で 卵にはね サイズもありまして
サイズもありましてね
エスもありますけど あれは栄養分の量であって
命のところは同じです
まあ無精卵であっても
やっぱり皆さんも卵割ったりして
あのところちょっと捨てちゃう
捨てちゃう ほんのちょっとあるでしょ
あれはひよこが出るところない
そこでそこはひよこなんです
成長すると 卵あってからそれは取って捨てますけどね
別に理由があるんじゃなくて
なんとなく別に見えますから
取るだけですよ あれ食べて毒になるとか
そういう理屈は何もないんです
この白い米をね 白くなるまで磨く場合はビージャのとこもう取ってしまうんですね
胚芽米といって それを取らないで皮を剥いて売ってる米もありますね
それでこの何でしたっけ
ハタアワカサという言葉の意味ないですけど
同じ時間かけて説明するのは
で 種がいくら大きくても
あの小さな芽が見えるところにほんのちょっと何か針でもちょっと一回だけ針を刺しておくとどうなるんですかね
時々すごいデッカい種もありますね
大きい種っていうのは何か思い浮かぶ種がありますかね
アボカドの種が結構大きいんです
私の経験で言えば アボカドよりもココナッツ見たことありますか？ココナッツ
あれ あのまま種なんですね
あの外の皮剥いちゃうと芽が3つあります
あれは騙すためにあるんです
その中で 1個が芽が出るところなんです
あれはもう指の爪ででもちょこっと取れます
すごい柔らかいんです
だからこんな大きいね
手では取れますけどね
大きいココナッツであっても
あの 目は丸い目は３つありますけど
あの真ん中にある丸くなっている柔らかいところは
もう芽が出るところです
そこをちょこっと何か刺して刺しちゃえばそれで終わり
もう芽が出ない しかし
そのままここに何ともこともないんです
そういうわけで このいくら栄養たまってあっても業として
あの誕生させる あの小さな力だけ抜けちゃうと
もう安心です このハターヴァーカサのこのチャンスを消した
なくした 壊した どんなチャンスかというと
業があるんですが この業のあのビージャーナのところを全部壊しているんです
だから悟りに達したっても
あの大量の業があるんですが
全部芽が出るところは全部壊しているんです
一発で 放射線が出たような感じで
ちょっと放射線が出ただけで大量の種なんですけど
栄養もそのままなんですけど
もう誕生はできません
で 修行して解脱に達すると
業消えるということじゃないんです
もう溜まったエネルギーだから
そんな消えるって言ったら
それぐらいのエネルギーを何て言いますか
解放してあげないと ではなくて
この業にあるこの転生させる力だけ無効になるんです
だからチャンスは残してないんです
転生するチャンスは 無の川ない
全くも 預流果に悟ったら七回生まれるというでしょ
ということはもう七個しかないんです
芽が出る種は 種は大量にあります
が 芽が出ない 七回芽が出たら終わり
阿羅漢になったら全部終わりということで
そういうわけで ハターヴァーカサっていうのは
このチャンスは壊しましたと
どんなチャンスかというと
転生するだろうというこの恐れ
それだけ壊しています
業を壊しましたとは まああまりはあまり使わない
まあ使う時もありますけど
だから無量の業を持っている人が修行して悟る
が 無量の業そのまんまなんです
しかし 全部無精卵みたいな卵ですね
もういくら温めてもヒヨコに変わるということは全くもあり得ない
[背景音楽]はい 次の最後の単語に行きます
ワンターソー まあアーサっていうのはこのやるべきことですね
それって結構生きるためのエネルギーになります
あれもやらなくちゃ これもやらなくちゃとかね
その何とかやりたい やりたい
やらなくて やらなくちゃという
それ かなりのストレスですよ
トゥドゥリストがあればあるほど
すごい相当ストレスなんです
そこでスケジュールは真っ白で何もない TODO
todo リストはそれも人間のストレスなんですね
なんででしょうかと やること何もなくてという
それ何かやることあるということで
人間は 生命は必死で業を起こして
起こして起こして輪廻転生するんです
いくら輪廻転生しても
もうこりごり いいやという気分になりません
何かやることを探すんです
で 私たちにはその煩悩あることは明白でしょう
例えば もう体調が崩れちゃって
医者が 2 日間病院で休みなさいと言われて
じゃあ 2 日間何すればいいかと
何か計画立てるんです
2 日間入院しなくちゃいけないんですから
2 日間だったら まあこれ持ってこれ持っていって
テレビも持っていってとかね
で 音楽はこれぐらい持っていってとかね
まあやるべき仕事は全部作って持っていくんですね
やるべきことあるとストレス溜まるし
やるべきことがないとまたストレス溜まっちゃうし
それって病気ですよ 何やっても結局意味がないでしょうに
病院で 2 日間ずっと聞きたがっている音楽は全部聞きましたと
だからで何になるんですかね
全部捨てて死ぬし しかし
やることがないとイライラするんですね
あの精神的なあの状況
やることが欲しい欲しいとTODOリストが長ければ長いほどありがたいと思いつつも
長くなるとこんなのはできかねて
またもうまた悩むという
だから やることはたくさんある人は
スケジュールはたくさんある人は
ああ嫌だ こんなのやめて休みたいと
それもやることなんですけど
別なことをやりたくなっちゃうし
どうしても心の中でそういう何か精神的な病気になる何か衝動が常にあるんです
それがなかなか消えないんです
一つやるやりたいことをやって終わった途端
次何やろうかなとかもう出ているんです
これが修行でなくなるんです
何かやらなくちゃというあのイライラ状態
あのストレスはさっぱり消えて安穏になるんです
で 悟った人のことを説明する場合は
なすべきことは成し終えたという言葉よくありますね
カタンカラニア だから一般人にとってはなすべきというところで結構苦しんでるんです
なすべきことって でも勝手に決めてますからね
生命としてなすべきもの
本当に法則として決まってます
それはやりません 誰も
それではなくて 別なこと
音楽を聴かなくてはとかね
ラーメン食べなくてはとかね
旅行しなくてはとかね
どうでもいいことはリストに入れるんです
友達に電話しなくてはとかね
今は誰にも友達もいないし
しかし 携帯ほど忙しい機械はね
世の中で どうでもいい
くっだらないことばっかりやってるんですね
いろんなブログを見たり書いたり
あれ 相当病気だと思いますね
で そうやってやるべきことっていうのを
生まれたならば なんで生まれたのかい？とね
生まれて生きることに意味があるのかいと
生まれたならばどうするべきかという
そこは調べればいいのにね
それはもう管轄外と どんなブランドのカバン使いますかとかね
どんなメーカーの履き物を履きますかとかね
誰のデザインの服を着ますかとかね
それは必死で もうカタログの中もうもう一メートルぐらい高くあって
これ調べながらやるべきことを探してるんです
そんなことってのは 生命として何の役にも立ちませんね
それで修行する人は 生命としてなすべきことをなして終わっちゃうんですね
それでトゥーどぅーリストは全部消えちゃうんです
仕事を完了したっていうことでなんです
最後の言葉その意味なんです
ワンターソー このなすべき
あれやらなくちゃ これやらなくちゃというそのエネルギーをワンともう全部終わっているんだと
捨てているんだと はい
セウェイウッタマポーリソー
そのような人こそが偉大なる
いわゆる尊い人であると
それが尊い人の定義ですね
この注釈書のエピソードでは
お釈迦様のこの偈を聞いた坊さんたちはみんな阿羅漢に達しましたよと書いてますけど
注釈書の説明はほんのほんのちょっと
もう五行も使ってないんですけど
私は何時間もかけて説明もしましたけどね
はい それで何か聞きたいこととか
質問とかそれについて
はい 今のですね サンディッチーとーと
それからハター ハターソーの違いをお伺いしたいんですけども
サンディッチーとーは液体というジャンクションを破壊するということで
それをする人は あの ハターカーサ
チャンスを破壊する 業
転生する業というのも破壊する
という理解でよろしいでしょうか
うん まあサンディッチーといえば
専門的に言えば活害を破壊するということで
ハターカーサということは
このカーマピージャですね
はい カルマのビージャ機能をなくすということになります
まあ結局は全部同じ意味ですけどね
まとめてみれば あまり仏教用語としてちょっと難しいと言っても疑問になるのはワンターソーなんです
普通はアーサはワンターサウォーっていうのは普通よくある
でもアーサをワンタっていうのは吐き出してるっていうアーサになってくると
うーん まあブッダの長老はそういう風に説明してますから
その通りに説明したんですけどね
カッタッバキッチャッスカタッタという解説ですね
サッバーアーサーエミナーワンターティワンターソー
はい 他質問ございますか？ はい
あの夜間の位に達した人はあと回生まれるっていう話ですけど
その回の間にまた元に戻っちゃうっていうことがあるんでしょうか
元ってどこ？ あのまた夜間の位を失う
それはあり得ません はい
ビージャもうなくなってますからね
回数券が持ってないんだからね
使っちゃえばどうしてももう解脱に達しなくちゃいけない
回生まれるということは
この結局この人間界に生まれる場合なんです
人間界には生まれても悟って預流果になった人は預流果なんです
まあ大体は戻れませんだからね
心は汚れないし もう天界に生まれちゃうしね
たまに生まれる場合あります
生まれても小さい時からもうすごい
もうその そのなくなった分はないんです
はい うーん  無料の業に無料の芽があるわけですよね
無料の業といったってば
こういう個一個ですから
一個一個にあります  それはたくさんある
と修行していくと その業を一つずつ潰していく
それじゃなくて まあ渇愛なくなりますから
それで業の機能を失うんです
だから私たちに渇愛あるんだから
このビージャのこの誕生させる能力が保つんです
すべて無常だから そんなに無限にエネルギーはね
賞味期限無限ということはありえないんです
一切無常だから 業も無常であるはずなんです
しかし 私たちはこの渇愛によって
ずっとこのビージャの機能
誕生させる機能をもう変わらないようにしているんです
例えばね もうあの もみでも一年二年に達すと芽が出なくなっちゃいますよ
しかし それをちゃんと保管しておけば
ずっともう 温度を管理して
湿度を管理して 冷凍するかもう冷蔵するかわかりませんだけど
何年でも保ちますね だからそこも無常の世界だから
そこはずっとやらなくちゃいけないんです
アメリカであのシードバンクというものがあるでしょ
世界であらゆる植物の種をバンクとか置いといて
かなり金かけてもう管理しているんです
だからといって毎日大量のエネルギーを使って電気を使って
そこは維持しなくちゃいけない
我々はすーっと渇愛やるんだから
それでもう喪う失なる過去の業まで
ビジャの機能 誕生させる機能を補完するんです
それで悟った人がパッと渇愛が消えちゃうんですね
で 消えます だからビジャの場合でもね
もう空気も入らない もう全部もうもうすごい厳しくあれ締めて管理してるでしょ
いきなり電気が消えた瞬間
いきなり暑くなっちゃって 1
日2日で終わり 全部種はダメになっちゃうんです
そんなような感じですね
業の場合も だから一個一個潰してって無料にやるんだから
これはありえないんです
その渇愛を がなくなれば良くなるとことですけど
渇愛がなくなれば その後はもう悟りに見入っちゃうということなんですが
渇愛自体はなくそうとする
それとも発見すればいい
あれ使ってください 渇愛がなくなれば悟りの境地になる
その渇愛をなくす努力をする
それとも渇愛を発見する努力をする
渇愛を発見しますか？これは発見することじゃない
だから死にたくないでしょうに
そんなに発見するまでもないんです
我々の知らないのは なんで死にたくないのかっていうことなんです
なんでそういう結論に達しているのかと
それがわからないでしょ
それ発見しなくちゃいけないんです
渇愛はもう簡単です 例えば
人生はいくら苦しくたっても
あ 死にたいなとか思わないんですね
あまりにも欲望は異常な人は自殺しますけど
普通の人は 欲望 普通の人はそれでも死にたく死にたいとは思わないんですね
だからそれは渇愛ということで
だから答えはこれなんですね
一切は無常であると 何のも実体のない
まあ幻想 幻覚であるということをわかってないんです
それをわかった途端 もう死ぬ
死にたく死にたいでも死にたくないでも
どちらでもなくなっちゃうんです
自我の意識が消えちゃうんです
自我っていうのは錯覚やと
自我っていうことはない
人は死にたいとも思わない
死にたくないとも思わないし
輪廻転生したいとも思わないし
思えなくなっちゃうんです
それが渇愛消えた状態なんです
それには無常を発見するしか他の方法はないんです
無常のね 全て 無常なのに気づかないだけでしょうに
すべて無常で成り立っているのに
それ気づかないんですね
だから修行者は渇愛なくそう渇愛なくそうという努力はしない
単純に観察するだけ 観察していると
本当の無常はね 気づいちゃう
発見してしまっちゃうし
同時にもういいやと それで渇愛は消えてるんです
その人は業のこのビジャ機能をね
誕生させる機能をなんとかなくさなくそう思わない
何も思わないんです ただひたすら気づきを実践するだけ
はい まだ質問がございますか
今月後のパデュマダにガンダーヴァっていう言葉が出てくるんですけども
転生する心のことを説明するところでですね
これは命を終えて そして次生まれる母体を探して
そこに結晶していくという過程の説明なんですけども
ガンダーヴァっていうのはどこからどこまでをガンダーヴァと呼んでるんでしょうか
それは全然経典では説明ないんです
経典でもガンダーヴァの言葉は 1箇所しか出てないでしょ
1箇所  2  3箇所あるんだけど
同じフレーズを繰り返してるだけです
だから正直全然説明はできませんし
まあすごいブッダの専門用語だったら
ブッダはちゃんと丁寧に解説するでしょうに
単純にね 例えば言いたかったのは
おそらく母の卵子と精子が組み合わせただけで誕生はしませんよと
ちょっと何か心がそこに着かないと
精子卵子だけで合体したところで植物ですね
生命にはならないんですね
だからおそらくそれにはね
よくインド人が使ってる単純にね
ガンダーヴァという言葉を使ったんじゃないんですかね
私はそう思う 説明ないんだからね
いろんなお坊さんたちやら
いろんな大乗仏教の宗派やら
いろいろ説明するんですけど
もう根拠ないところで勝手にどんな説明したってもね
これは当てにならないんです
大乗仏教になってことの 7 日間
どこに生まれようかなと探してるんだと
それって法則的にはありえないんですね
一つ変わると次のものは同時に生まれてるんですね
隙間がないっていうのは因果法則なんです
ですから 死の瞬間で何かに変わっているんです
それでも大乗仏教というか
部派仏教ではね まあ 3ヶ月間とも言うし
7 日間とも言うしね だったら勝手に考える数字ですから
7年とか言ってもいいんじゃないんですか
49年も探してるんだとかね
言ったっても 別に経典からそういう根拠ないんだから
それも人間の感情だと思いますね
大体人が亡くなったら
その悲しみショックっていうのは
大体 7 日目でなんとなく落ち着いてきますよ
例えば 人が死んで激しくショックを受けた人であっても
もう 7 日間ぐらい経ってくると認めてしまう
まあしょうがない 死んじゃったと
そういう人間の感情的なところから言ってるんじゃないかなと思いますよ
で 何か言うためには証拠が必要ですね
私たちにはその証拠もないしね
だから私は経典でないものっていうのはもう説明しないんです
で カタワットゥではそのアントラバウのね
あのアンタラバ何て言いますか？アンタラバパーリ日本語で
中 えーと 中はあると言ったですからね
あの施設栽培の人々はね
で カタワットの論はもうじゃあ欲界・色界・無色界と三界ある
で どれぐらい？三界でしょうと
欲界・色界・無色界 生命は誕生する次元は
それははっきりしてますね
それははっきりしてます
それでウブの生命は色界ですか？欲界ですか？色界ですか？無色界ですか？というと答えられなくなっちゃうんですね
じゃあその三つから離れているんでしょうかというと
解脱しているということになりますからね
いえ 離れて じゃあ三界のどこかでしょうにと
色界にあらぞと 無色界にあらぞと
欲界にもあらぞと だったら何だと
だからこれはもうあなた方はいい加減でもうその話は成り立ちませんと言っているんです
まあそんなもう説明するとなんか他の関係ないこといっぱいたぶらかしますから
うん はい マイクロフォン
えーと 今日の話はなかなか非常に難しくて
あの 日本語とパーリ語の差っていうことを最近ちょっと経典なんか読んでると感じるんですが
日本語の場合は 例えば善悪という話で
善とか悪とかいうと 善というと善以外の意味はないですよね
善という意味以外の意味がないんですよね
ところがパーリ語ですと
例えば今回みたいなやつでも
善と善と悪の間をかなり自由に同じ言葉行き来することがあり
ちょっと最近思ったのはあれなんですね
あの 承知という言葉ありますよね
サンパジャーン あれで日本語で承知というと承知以外の意味はないですよね
ところがパーリ語ですと
あのサンパジャーン ムサワーデーとか言って
意識的に嘘をつくということだと
嘘をつくより普通あんまり意識しないで嘘をつくよりももっと悪く
あの悪の方向へ引っ張る意味で
あのサンパジャーンというのを言葉使ってるわけですね
ところが我々がそのサンパジャーンというのを承知と言ってしまったら
承知の嘘ってありえないわけですね
だから承知って言ったらもう承知以外の意味がないと
その場合は承知の上で嘘ついてるということですね
それは冗談です だから
あの なんか日本語に訳せ
訳せない言葉というのが結構あるのか
まあブッダが善悪の間を自由に言葉で行き来できるような能力があって
我々の方は非常に固定的なね
善と悪とかいうと 本当に善と言って善以外の全部悪いことの意味を表すことは不可能ですよね
日本語の場合は  まあそれはパーリ語にしても善というね
クサラと言えば悪いことは意味しませんだけど
でもパーリ語の場合はそれがいっぱいありますね
種類がね 以前の言葉 だから結構その日本語にできないパーリ語が
今日の話なんかちょっと日本語にできないような
今日はちょっと日本語にできない
できないよね このバンタソーとかこういう話になると
ちょっと  今日の偈は本当は日本訳できない
なんか不可能という感じがして
このままやっぱり覚えるしかないのかなという感じが私は
本当は私はすごい 何ですごい時間かかるのかと
そういうシンプルな偈を説明するために
この言語の問題ですね
だからこのパーリ文化もありますから
インドの当時の文化もありますが
お釈迦様自身の仏教文化というものもありますから
その背景に沿ってずっと説明して説明して
現代人の文化背景に入れておくんですね
それはすごい時間かかるんです
もうさっさと直訳できればありがたいんだけどね
そうはうまくいかないんです
特にあえてあの この前のダンマパダの講義の場合でも
時間ちょっと残ったのにこの偈は触らなかったんですよ
今日はこれで終了しましょうと
触らなかったのは これには結構苦労するだろうということをね
あったんだから まあ 1 日かけて説明しなくちゃいけないと知っていたんです
まあ一応でおっしゃることはその
例えば私は今日は善悪ではなくて行為という言葉を使ったでしょ
それどちらでも入ってるでしょ
そちらには だからあえて別な日本語の単語を作るんです
作るって使うんです だから生きている上では行為しているんだと
生きていることが行為であると
それが善でもあり 悪でもあり
だから善悪と行為ですね
行為を二分化するために何か尺度が必要なんですね
その尺度は まあ楽しみ
喜びを与えるエネルギーは善にするし
苦しみを与えるエネルギーは悪にするということで
だから行為という一言でどちらでもよろしいということになっちゃうんです
そこで今日は全部そうやって善も悪もまとめた偈なんですね
例えばハターヴァカーサ
チャンスを壊すと チャンス壊すということは
地獄に行くチャンスだけではなくて
すべての天界に生まれる
梵天に生まれるチャンスまで一切壊すということなんです
いわゆる悪も善も壊す
サンプジャヤーナの場合は
やっぱりあの サンプジャヤーナっていうのは瞑想で使う場合はわざと意識するっていうことですね
手を上げる上げる上げるという場合は
あえてわざと強引に意識してる
するんですね 同じ機能を使ってますよ
サンプジャヤーナ ムサーワーダの場合は
これは事実じゃないと知っているにも関わらず
あえて工夫して別なことを言う
あのあえて工夫するという意味でサンプジャヤーナですね
まあ言ったんだけど 言ったことは調べてない
事実になっ 嘘になったということを嘘にならないんですね
だから嘘を言う時も その人が意識が必要なんですね
自分が嘘をついているんだと
この人を騙しているんだと
その意識があって罪になるんです
だから上沼恵美子さんの話は嘘にならないんです
あれまで嘘を言える人間
すごい才能でしょうね
なのに嘘の罪にはなりませんね
無駄話ですけどね 無駄話の罪はあるかもしれませんだけど
嘘の罪にはならないんです
騙す気持ちはみじんもないんだから
それで小室哲哉さんが嘘つきでしたからね
黙ったんだから 何億円も音楽家のね
逮捕されましたしね まあそんなことでもやっぱり意識するっていうことですね
だからヴィパッサナーで使う単語も使うんで
ヴィパッサナーの場合でも普通は誰も気づかないで生きてますから
修行っていうのは気づいていくる
歩く時も座る時も寝る時でも
大便小便する時にもあえて気づくという
[背景音楽]そういうことだから
どちらでも パーリ語なら別に全然違和感はないんです
もう少し日本語にパーリ語が言語のやつを日本語として取り入れる必要はやっぱりあるだろうなという
そういうのもありますね
多分ね 難しいですよね
難しいと思いますね  パーリ語で読めるようになるのがやっぱり一番いいってことが一番いいことですね
日本語の能力も相当必須になりますからね
下手に漢訳の中国で訳した仏教用語使っちゃうと
なんかなんかなんかやったなって感じはするけども
結局中身が何もなかったり
で そちらのどっちかというと
やっぱり漢字っていうのは神秘主義の方向へ一文字でなんかいっぱい意味が含まれているような気がするわけなんで
だからちょっとあれは確かにテーラワーダ仏教を修行するための下準備としての漢訳の用語がたくさんあるっていうのは非常に一見ありがたいわけですけど
逆にそっちの方にあんまり頼っちゃうと
すごくそっちで遊んでしまうというか
言葉で遊んでしまうというところが
それもよくありますね
やっぱり漢文だけ読む人々は漢字で遊んでみるんですね
漢字で 漢字で遊んで解説しますけど
元の意味とは何の関係もなくなっちゃうんですね
質問はあるんですか？いや
そうしたら大丈夫です
ありがとうございます
今日のお話の中で 我々は何かを信じてしまうという弱みを持っているというような表現があったかと思うんですけども
考えてみると本当にそうだなとは思うんですけれども
もう少しその弱みということについてですね
お話をいただけないかなと
例えば渇愛ということと
それがどう関係するのかしないのかという
全部関係ありますね やっぱりもう生きてることだから
全部関係ありますね それはそんなに
例えば信仰することも渇愛だからでしょ
結局は 調べたくないしね
まあそういうことで信じてしまうというね
一番わかりやすい単純な例で言えばね
神を信仰すれば罪が全部滅びますよと言ったと
あ そんな便利なこと ありがたいことはないと言って
神を信仰して洗礼を受けて参拝しちゃうという
綺麗さっぱりだと勘違いする
これ渇愛なんです あなたの行為の結跡に持ちなさいと言っちゃうと
やばいと思っちゃうでしょ
それで自分には愛着 悪いことはしたいんだけど
悪い結果が嫌やという我がまま働いてますね
そういうへりくつな人々にとっては
神っていうのはすごい簡単に救われる概念なんです
だから信仰してしまうんです
だからそこでちゃんと渇愛働いてますよ
まあそれはまあ信仰 信仰がなくても
無神論者であっても 我々には信仰する弱みがあるんです
それでどこに生まれるかというと
この知らないというね
ことから生まれるんです
知らないということは現実でしょ
で 赤ちゃんが何も知らないでしょ
親を信仰しなくちゃいけないんですね
学校に入った子供は何も知らないでしょ
先生を信仰しなくちゃいけないんです
だからそうなってるんですね
生命のシステムが で 動物でも飼ってみると
飼い主を信仰しちゃうんですね
動物は自分の人間に対して渇愛があるんです
それでちゃんと面倒見てくれると
もうその人にべったしつくんです
それも信仰の機能なんです
何も考えてないんですけど
動物は 考えなくても信仰はちゃんと機能しています
だから誰もその問題から自由になったわけじゃないんです
悟りに達しなくちゃいけないと
とにかく それで初めて悟ったということは
信仰する弱みが消えるというね
で 生きるとは何かと発見するんですね
それでも誰の話も信仰する必要なくなっちゃうんです
誰が何か喋っても 何かしら生きることに関係があるんです
まあ例えば 子供たち喜んで読むいろいろ怪獣物語やらね
もう神話的な物語いっぱいあるでしょ
で もうありえないのは当たり前でしょうね
ありえないのは当たり前ですけど
その中で人間の感情を語られてるんですね
その時は木に宿ってた神が
神様が降りてきて あなたには
あの 何て言います 何て言います
希望を三つ与えますよと
何かくれましたと 希望するものはして
この種を投げて下さいと
いう場合はありえない話でしょ
希望なら何でもいいやと
しかし 希望を叶ってほしいという人間の感情があるんですね
それがストーリーにしているだけ
だから 生きるとは何かと知った人にとっては
これは渇愛の働きを物語にしているだけだと知ってます
だから あの 本当に気をつけなくちゃいけないんですよ
あの 信仰の弱みはね 強ければ強いほど迷惑なんです
狂暴で疑って当たる人々は人類のために何かするんです
科学はそういうことでしょう
教会に対立して やっちゃったんですね
それで人類は大変助かってますよ
どう見たっても じゃあキリスト教で世界中広げて
どんな程度で人を助けてますか？アフリカいろんなところに行ってね
あの金いっぱい持っていって
人にいろんなことやってるでしょ
もうボランティアやったりとかね
自分たちが戦わせて それから助けに行くでしょ
もうアメリカで一部が行って人を殺したり
財産を奪ったり あれやこれやと政府をおかしくしたり
もういろんな騒動を起こしたりして
それから一緒にキリスト教のグループが行って
まあテントを張って キャンプ難民キャンプを作って
まあ食事を配ったりしていいことやってますね
で では その人々も じゃあ仮に社会に貢献していると思いましょう
教会が社会に貢献している行と
科学が社会に きょう きょう
何でしたっけ 貢献している行はどうですかね
科学の貢献というのは全ての人類に入ってるでしょ
だから信仰ない方がありがたいんです
そういうふうに あの 現実に見るためには結構勇気が必要なんですよ
例えば神という概念がこの石器時代
洞窟の中の人間が作った概念だと
何でもないんだと いうためにはかなり勇気が必要なんです
預言者たちはみんな精神的にイカれていたんだというためには
しかし それ事実です 現代心理学に照らし合わせるとみんな病気です
一人のイエスのなんか預言者がウンコ食べてたんだからね
相当神のすげがあったでしょうね
で またあのイエスを洗礼したというジョン・ヨハネ
あれまた変なもの食べてた人でしょ？ロカツっていうのなんでったっけ
あの虫がいるんですよ
緑色の  イナゴですか  イナゴ
イナゴともう一つ何か食べてるんですね
相当病気でしょ それから旧約聖書のテキストを書いた人々は
学者としては学者で文章を書けましたからね
学者っていうのは言葉覚えて書けるだけのことで
しかし 精神的にはすごいイカれているということはよくわかりますね
なぜならば 一貫して殺せ殺せというメッセージでしょ
潰せ 敵を殺せとか そこは一貫するために神という概念も作っちゃうんですね
神はすごく優しいんだと
だから神を信じていない人は子供まで殺せと
そこを屁理屈言ったら相手が病気ということは正真正銘でしょう
でもそれ言うためには相当勇気が必要なんです
ということで 他の人々はもうやばいんだからもう黙っていようとかね
それでまあそれは信仰型ですね
やっぱり もしかするといたらどうしますか？とかね
よくわからんだから この会もこの会も一応両方拝んでおこうかなとかね
あのヒンドゥー教の人々っていうのはへっちゃらでね
マリア様にもお祈りするわ
イシュバラ神にもお祈りするわ
そこら辺に適宜にある神にお祈りする
で あの日本に住んでる場合は
毎日へっちゃらで ちゃんと神社があったら行って
ちゃんとお祈りして仕事に行くんです
だから日本の神の概念っていうのは
インドの神の概念とはものすごく違うんだけど
うん 全くの違う概念ですけど
ヒンドゥー人はもうものすごい信仰だから
まあどっちかようわからないんだけど
まあ一応この神にでも祈りしておきましょうと
まあどちらでもOKやと
だから当たり外れよくわからないんだから全部買っておくんですね
どちらが当たるだろうと
一つも当たりませんだけどね
ヒンドゥー系の人って面白いもので
あえてキリスト教という風な人もいますけど
そうでもなくて カトリック教会に行ったら
友達がいて 関係あったならば堂々と行って活動もするし
賛美歌も歌うし 全部やっちゃいます
それでそれから仕事は別なところに行く羽目になっちゃったら
そちらプロテスタントだったらその教会に行くんです
そこで友達で自分の家でパーティーやる場合は
家ではもう一緒の神のあれちゃんと祀っているんです
そこでインド式なりに線香を立てて明かりをつけて
もういろいろサンスクリット語の言葉言ったりして
そこでちゃんと祈りするんです
彼らがだから哲学的に考えると思って
すべての宗教は同じやと
もう相当無知だと思いますけどね
私はびっくりするのは
なんでお釈迦様がインドに生まれたのかと
インド人に合わないんです
全くもってあんなアホ道ではね
あの無知度ではね まるっきり救う方法もないんです
喋ったっても また難しいんです
論理はできてますから
理論とかね 結構難しいんです
まあだから信仰っていうのはやっぱり弱みということなんです
怖いと思っちゃえば何にも挑戦もできんでしょ
人生では 怖い やばいと思っちゃえばね
まあだからみんな勇気の悪い人はやってみるんです
そこでも当たれば人生人間はもう幸福になるし
外れればもうそれはしょうがないということで
先生 あの大般若経に出てくるワジー国の人に
お釈迦様が国をちゃんと保つために七つの教えを守りなさいっていうのがいくつか出てくるんですけど
七井不酔大宝という名前です
それで先祖の祭りとか
伝統的な宗教をちゃんと守りなさいというような項目が出てくるんですけど
それっていうのはどちらかというと
なんかその まあヒンドゥー教的な態度に近いのかなという気もちょっとして
あれは政治論です 政治家がどんな宗教の人も管理しなくちゃあかんでしょ
だから政治家がみんなに愛されなきゃ政治できないんですね
統治できないんですね
だから仲間はどうでもいいんだから
そのその地方の人々を祀っている
そういう霊地とかなんとかってのは
お前も行きなさいよと言って
ちゃんとやってくださいと
そうすると誰にも何とも文句言えなくなりますね
信仰しなさいではないんです
全く信仰する必要ないんです
あれは政治的な 態度ですね
みんなを仲良くしなくちゃいけないんですね
みんなと で 一応スリランカの仏教の連中もね
大体イスラム教のモスクにはね
もう立ち入り禁止ですからね
イスラム人以外は 神ってすごいハイタス的で
神がお首をもので 力がなくて
他の神を信仰してない人が入っちゃうと汚れちゃって大変なことになるんです
伝染病にかかるんです
だからもう普通は誰も行きませんが
スリランカの場合 上政治家はもうほとんど仏教徒ですけど
特に大統領とかね 総理とかになる人々はね
ちゃんと大統領になったらちゃんと行きます
大統領になってから最初の活動として
まずお寺に行って祝福を受けて
それからカトリック教会の一番トップところに行って
またそこでちゃんとメサをやって祝福を受けて
それからイスラム人のモスクにも行きます
その場合はみんなすごく喜んで
今日は大統領来るんだと待ち構えていて
花束やら花はいろいろ持っていて
ちゃんと受け取って連れて行って
もうアッラーフアッバールとかなんとか言って処遇してもう帰れます
だからそこはみんな仲良くするっていうね
でなきゃ政治できんでしょうに
お釈迦様はすごい現代人的にそれを教えてるんです
わかりました  はい マイクロ
今日のお話の中で 2つ質問があるんですけど
自分の中でわからないことがあって
私が輪廻転生のわからない場合
どうやって調べることができるのかっていうことと
あと病気を小さい時からしょっちゅう持ってるんですけど
その因果とか業によってそれができているというようなお話があったと思うんですが
そのそれによってできていることを調べることができないっていうところで
今日 科学との 要するに信仰っていうところでお話があったと思うんですけど
私はそういうものがないと
そういうものがないっていうことについて
自分の中で なんでしょうか
わからない あるかどうかがわからないっていう感覚があって
それについてどうやって調べたらいいのかお願いします
あのね 調べられるものも調べられないものもありますね
我々は調べるってことを自分持っている能力で調べるでしょ
能力で知られたものだからね
何でもかんでも調べられるわけじゃないしね
私たちもね 地球は宇宙から見ればさすがに美しく見えるでしょうと思いますけど
私は見たい 見れればありがたいなと思ってますけど
無理でしょ だからそういうことはね
事実であっても調べられないものっていうのもありますしね
我々の能力はそんなにあるわけじゃないんです
ですから いわゆるプラクティカル的に現実的になるんです
合理的になるんです 合理的になったらこういう考えになるんです
仏教は人が死んだ瞬間にまた生まれるっていうことは言うし
他の連中は無いとも言うし
しかし仏教はこの原因に結果があるんだっていう話なんですね
それは今も自分が生きている場合は
この原因結果のおかげで生きているんですね
まあとりあえず輪廻があってもなくても
悪いことをすると悪い結果になるし
良いことをすると良い結果になるし
何か良いことをしておくんだと
ずっと悪いことをやめちゃいますよと
そうなってくると 2つのことを考えられます
1つは輪廻がないと推定する
輪廻がないと推定していても
自分が得をしているんです
すごく良い人間に生きていたんだから
もう生きている間でも幸せで
みんなと仲良くできちゃって
すごい幸福に生きていて
もうあっけなく死んじゃったって全然悔しくはないんです
もし輪廻があると推定してみると大丈夫です
悪いところに行けないでしょうに
いい行為をしてきた だから人が死んで本当に生まれるのかいということは調べる方法ないんです
ありますけど それは我々にはオープンじゃないんです
宇宙船に乗っちゃえば見えますが
我々にはそれクローズされているでしょう
はい どうそうとは言わないでしょう
だから この心の働きを観察する能力を身につけば
これはよくわかるんです
これを結構結構厳しい仕事になっちゃうんです
瞑想しなくちゃいけないんです
そこまでダメな人間にっていいわけじゃないでしょうに
やがて瞑想して超越した能力身についたらわかるんだから
その時信じますと そこまであんたどうするのかいと
生きていることは日々の仕事でしょ
だから良いことをして生活しましょうよと
悪いことをするもう人はね
私はもう先のことを考えませんよと
今さえ良ければいいやということで生きてますよという場合は
悪いことをして生きているでしょ
で 万が一輪廻転生ないと推定してみると
この人は悪人だから みんなに嫌われちゃって
逮捕されたりして 処刑にされたりして
もう財産奪われたり 政府に取られたりして
あらゆる苦しみを味わうんですね
社会人としてはもう認められなくて
惨めに生きる羽目になるんです
もし輪廻があると推定してみると
さらにやばいんです 悪行為したんだから
だから一般人には輪廻があるとお釈迦様が説かれても
それははい わかりましたということはありえないんです
ですから お釈迦様はこの教えを教えて
こういうふうに教えてくださいと
あなた方にはこれわからないんだよとはっきり言ってるんです
それにはもう瞑想して
禅定に達して 心を追ってチェックする能力というものを育てなくちゃいけないんです
これまた人の能力っていうのはみんなにできるわけじゃないんです
野球の場合でも イチローみたいになりたいと思っても
あんたに手足あるんだからできるでしょうと
とはないでしょ やっぱりそういう能力の差もありますから
瞑想は進んでも その特定の能力はつくかつかないかわからないんです
とにかく輪廻を自分で発見するということが必要な条件ではありません
渇愛をあることがわかったら解脱に達しますから
これ知らなかったらもうダメだとか必要な条件じゃないんです
しかし 輪廻否定する権利もないんです
否定するためには証拠が必要です
肯定するためにも証拠ないと同時に
否定するためにも証拠はないんですね
もう一つ だから自分が死んじゃったらね
どこかに生まれ変わるんだから
その時わかるでしょ 生まれ変わったと
その時もう遅いんですね
もう生まれ消えるんだから
しまったと もう私は輪廻転生しないと思ったのに
生まれてしまったと もうこの場所は嫌やと
もうじゃあ成り直しできんでしょうに
だからまあ個人個人で証明する方法っていうのは死んでみることですよ
でもそれは意味がないんですね
だからもういい加減余計なこと考えないで
いい行為して生きてみなさいと
いうのはブッダの戒めなんですね
で しかし否定することは良くないと思うんですね
わからないと言ってくださいと
その方が正直です 私は否定しますと言ったらもうアホです
肯定もできんものをどうやって否定するんですかね
で 否定はできないんだけど
なんとなく推測できるでしょうというのと
例えば人間っていうのは一人もいないでしょ
似ているものは 一卵性双生で生まれても
生きる道が変わっていく
性格が変わっていく 幸不幸のレベルが変わっていく
で それから行為に結果あるっていうことも明らかなんですね
それから我々の心っていうのは瞬間も停止しないんですね
心働いてるんです だから停止しないっていうことは
一つの心の特色なんですね
それだったら死で停止するはずがないんです
で 我々はこの脳に引っかかっていく
ちょっと混乱 今はね 混乱しているだけで脳じゃないんですね
生きる命ということは生きていることだからね
それからまあ心のエネルギーっていうのはすごい強烈っていうことがよくわかります
すべて我々は心のエネルギーでやってます
物質のエネルギーでやってるわけじゃないんです
物質のエネルギー使っているんですけど
心で使っているんです
車を組み立てるのも頭で考えて組み立てたんです
車に馬力あると これ物質で言ったってもね
人間がいなかったら 知恵
頭の働く人間いなかったら成り立ちませんね
そのまんま世界は何もなくて
だからこの地球もむちゃくちゃ変えたでしょうね
これ相当心の働きでしょ
そこで自分の体 個人で見ても
気分次第で体変化するんですね
体に心を変化させるっていうことはしょっちゅうそれほどできるんです
逆が一緒でも たまにね
もうお化粧でもして 好きな服を着て
鏡でね 顔を見たらね 女性の方々は結構決まってるんだとかね
いい気分になるかもしれませんだけど
あんまり持ちませんね
その気分 もうすっごいいい気分になって
自信満々で外へ出た途端
お母さんがなんでその服は？と言った言葉で終わりますね
なんだこれは だからせっかく時間かけてお化粧して服を選んできてね
もう美容院で髪の毛も作って頑張ったのに
いわゆる物質から心に喜びを与えようと一言葉で壊れる
例えば 好きな男の人とね
デートに行こうと思ってね
一生懸命おしゃれをして
いきなり男がなんのことなく
私はこの赤い色あまり好きじゃないとか何か言っちゃったら
ガクンと全部壊れてしまいますね
ですから 我々毎日それ経験しているでしょうに
ものを通って喜びを感じようと頑張っていますけど
あっけなく壊れますね
それが しかし 心を通して
今日はすごくなんて言いますか
浮き浮き気分ですごく楽しいんだとと言ったら
どこかに行って遊ぼうかなとかね
言うと あの気分は 1 日持ちますね
じゃあ今日はもう川のところに行って
もうハイキングでもして
自転車に乗っていろいろ午後はもうバーベキューやりましょうよと
それで最初からもう心にエネルギーがあるんですね
そうすると 1 日中持ちます
それでお母さんがあのね
今日一日遊ぶんじゃなくて
あんたにこれもこれもこれもあるでしょうにと言っても聞かない
その場合は  今日は遊ぶに決めてます
決まったんだから とかね
これは明日やりますと言って
あの言葉カットするんですね
だから心が誘導 主導権取っちゃうと結構持ちます
体が主導権取っちゃうとあっけなく壊れます
ということで エネルギーはすごいあるのは心なんです
それで私たちの体はすーっと髪の毛はいつ白くなるか
いつ音とか どれぐらいスピードで老けるかどうかね
あれって全部心次第なんです
だから生きる場合は肉体があって心があるというふうに 2つに分けて考えちゃうと
この中ですごい偉く管理しているのは心であるということはわかりますね
それが肉体壊れるとあっけなく消えるんだよということは
ちょっとあれほどエネルギーですから
エネルギーは消えませんだからね
物質は明らかに物質で心が弄らないと変化しません
変化しますけど それも分かっている変化なんですね
だから月も変化しますよ
地球と同じ年齢ですけど
しかし 地球の変化ほどないでしょう
ほとんど地球の変化とはもう比較にならない
なんで違う そんなに激しく変化するのかというと
生命がいるんだからなんです
水があるからじゃないんです
水の中にも生命がいるんです
ということで 心は支配者であるということは
お釈迦様は説かれているんですね
ですから 転生しないというよりはするだろうと推測した方がいいということになるのです
仮説立てる場合はね あの証拠を自分が住んでいるわけじゃないんです
仮説です 仮説を立てるために証拠を情報を揃えちゃうと
因縁があるんだろうだろうということになるんです
それで 今の自分が過去の行為の結果でしょうと
そうすると自分がこれって嫌やと思ったとしても変えられないでしょう
例えば女で生まれて嫌だな
これはと 男になりたいの？なりませんね
それで私たちの性格とかね
例えば朝寝坊する人がいるとしたって
嫌だな これはと思いつつも
毎日朝寝坊する 時間に遅れる人は悪い
悪い 悪いと思いつつも
毎回毎回時間に遅れる
いう風に 何か分かっても
自分にはどうも変えられない
何か生き方っていうのはもうできちゃってるんですね
だからそこは変化させているのはもう過去の業で
その業が出した結果だから
そのプログラムでいくということになりますね
はい  2番目の質問は この病気とか
あるいはこれの場合はですけど
で 業は自己管理するんですけど
ある一部だけなんですね
私はこれを現代的な別な例えで説明します
皆様みんなコンピューター使ってるでしょ
それでマイクロソフト会社のOS使ってるでしょ
自分のパソコンのOSは業と同じく何やってもOSの能力次第なんですけど
我々にとってはOSは全然要りません
我々は別なワープロのプログラムやらゲームのプログラムやらそれを使ってるんです
パソコンって面白いなと思うのは
自分好きなプログラム入れてるんだからなんです
しかし その好きなプログラムがWindowsがなければ動かないんですね Windows
の場合はね Macintosh
の場合は別なOSがありますけどもね
とにかくそのOSがないと動かないんですね
だからOSは一貫してあるパターンで裏で動いているんです
それに我々はそんなに気づく必要もないんです
好きなプログラムをインストールしちゃえばいいんです OS
そのものが使用者には役に立ちません
それで 私たちの人生の中で
過去の業がOSだと思ってください
それで役に立ちません
その上にどんなプログラムを載せるのかいということで
面白い人生が出来上がっちゃうんです
だから自分で自分の人生をプログラムすればいいんです
いくらプログラムしても OS
の能力によってちょっと引っかかることがあります
でもそれそんなにも気にすることでもないんで
時々ね まあ最近のコンピューターっていうのは 3ヶ月か半年で壊れるように作ってるでしょ
で ハードだけじゃなくてソフトもそうなんです Windows
なんか入れちゃうと 最初はすごい早く動くんですね
しかし 毎日重くなるように組んでるんです
なんとかキーというものがありまして
あれがもう何百万もキーが出てきて
あれ数字ですからね これ混乱しちゃうんです
32ビットでやってますから
長い数字ですけど あの 16進数のね
あれでプログラムを動かすんですけど
いくつか種類に分けてて
プログラムをインストールするたびにキーが変わっていって
新しいラインが入って
新しいラインが入ってとか
どんどん重くなっちゃって
それでさっさと立ち上がったプログラムをオンにしたら
じっと待たなくちゃいけないんですね
だからプログラムにOSによって邪魔されてますけど
ちょっと待つしかないんです
その場合は 起動するまで
嫌だったらまた死んで生まれ変わるしかない
その場合はコンピューターの場合は全部削除して新しくインストールしなくちゃいけないんです OS
からも 人間の場合は 我々は何かの業で生まれたんですけど
それはあんまり気づかないんですね
その上で何を勉強するのか
どんな生き方をするのかということによって
自分の今世の人生のプログラムが成り立ちます
まあやっぱりそれでももううまくいかないなと思ったら
死んで新しく生まれるしかないんですね
その場合はもっと立派なOSで生まれたいと思わなくちゃいけないんですね
すごい立派なOSで生まれるためには
またたくさん良いことをしておかないと
ということで どんなOSでも完璧じゃないんです
バージョンアップしなくちゃいけないんです Windows
7にしたっても だいたい２週間 ３
週間ごとにいつでもバージョンアップなんです
もしかすると私のパソコンの中身を調べると
バージョンアッププログラムでもう千
二千以上も入っていると思いますよ
あれで混乱するだろうと思いますけど
だから新しくバージョンアップしちゃうと
古いフレーズを削除しておけばいいのに削除しないんですね
ロールバックすることがあったらロールバックできるようにと置いておく
あれが結構ハンディになっているんです
何かバージョンアップしたところで気に入らなかったらロールバックという元に戻ることができます
から プログラムそのまま置いておくんです
そこでもうただの数字読むことだから
数字の列ですからね 一つ一つ互い違いでなければね
成り立たないし だから微妙に互い違いあっても
あまりにも似ていちゃうと勘違いする可能性が結構出ています
私のところも結構それ起こりますからね
相当勘違いしてとかね
で こういうこういうことだからこうなってるんだと
私は私がしたことじゃないんでしょうと言っても
別な方法で潰しちゃいますけどね
そういうことで 私たちの人生もだいたい何か似ているようなことなんですね OS
の上で生きてなくちゃいけないんですね OS
は過去の業で それに文句言ったって意味がないんです
その上 どんなプログラムを載せて仕事をするのかというね
だから まあ一応結論は簡単です
いつでも明るい心で 優しい心で
嫉妬 憎しみをしないで生きてみなさいよと
そうするともう結構OKになります
ちょこちょこと病気になったって落ちないで落ち込むんですかと
気にしないで明るい心で頑張っちゃえばもう何のこともないんです
それでみんな病気になったり
落ち込んだりする人っていうのは
ものすごいアホなことするんですね
あの人々なら本当に元気で頑張っているのに
それにしてみれば俺はと
とんでもない話なんです
あの人は本当にスマートで痩せていってるんです
それにしたら私はね もう太っとくとかね
これがそれ自体が悪行為なんです
他人と比べるたびに 自分がどんどんどんどんどんどんもうダメになっていくんです
自分は自分なんです 自分が明るく優しく
嫉妬 恨み 憎しみなく生きてみるんだよと
あの人は背が高くてかっこいいな
それにしても私はもうこれしかないんだとかね
150センチだと だから何やと私が言いたいんです
150センチで頑張ればいいんです
テレビ見ると結構あるんです
女性のタレントさんいますね
不細工といやらありゃしないんですね
彼女たちはその不細工であることが売り物に出していてボロ儲けている
そんなやり方なんです
だからもうバカにされるわ
もう女性に向かってそんなこととんでもないと思うんだけど
彼女たちは喜んで もういじめられて
バカにされてやられちゃって
もう無茶苦茶言われちゃって
もうそれでもうお金もらってるんだから
有名なタレントさんたちだから
一人の女の人がもう笑い芸人なんですけど
テレビで見ていて 一切でもすごい不細工
汚い かっこ悪いということばっかしそう見えちゃうんですね
ある日突然 新幹線で本人がいたんですね
あれ見てこの人何が不細工ですかと
もう普通のもう綺麗な女の子なんです
ただ 背がもうほどほどないんですけど
もうそれなりにもう美しく服を着て
もう